[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY YUEN: I've been doing
Android for about four years.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about the story of how
Facebook as a
company transitioned
from having a small mobile
team to a company that focuses
on mobile as a first priority.
So let me start
with a story here.
Back around 2010, 2011,
Facebook had a very, very small
mobile team.
For some context, if you
guys don't know about this,
Facebook started in 2004.
It started as a web application.
And then with transition--
with large number of devices
appearing in the market
and mobile being a very
important thing, Facebook
started a mobile team.
Around 2010, 2011, 11 which
is when I joined Facebook,
we still had a mobile team.
And we realized, well
it doesn't really
make much sense on how to
scale our app if we have
a mobile team, and the
rest of the company
is focusing on our
desktop application.
We had product developers,
project managers,
and product designers for
each feature in our website,
focusing only on www.
And we had a team that had
probably a dozen developers
focusing on
everything on mobile.
Well, so what do we do?
We realized that this
was not going to scale,
and we started building a bunch
of these experiences in mobile.
And as we finished
building them,
we transitioned the ownership
to each of the product teams.
We continue doing so.
As of today, we no
longer have mobile teams.
So if you guys come
and ask us, hey,
what is the size of your
mobile team at Facebook,
we just say the whole company
is focusing on mobile.
I really want to emphasize this.
So what happens here?
When we transition our company
into focusing fully on mobile,
we're injecting
hundreds of developers
into each of our
mobile code bases.
There a lot of
interesting challenges
that arise from this.
So I'll tell you a couple
stories around this.
So that's in the context of our
engineering size and culture.
But let's look at it from the
other point of view, our users.
As of today, we have 1.3
billion mobile monthly actives.
And they are using our
app all over the world
under different
network conditions.
You guys know about the
Android fragmentation problem.
It's a benefit, but also it's
an interesting challenge.
That means that there
are lots of people
in the world that
are able to have
internet connected devices now.
And because of
this, we're building
the-- we're in a really, really
good position where we're
building the
application that allows
them to connect with the world
and their friends and family.
So this is a graph
of the projection
of internet connected devices
in the next couple of years.
It's made by this third
party company called IDC.
And here I'm separating,
in the yellow section,
the developed markets, and the
blue ones, emerging markets.
Now, that sharp, sharp
ramp up, that sharp graph
indicates that in the
next couple of years,
we will have a ton of
users coming injected
into the Android ecosystem.
And they're not going to
have phones like the ones we
have in our pockets.
They're going to have phones
that probably have helped
the hardware set that back
in probably three years ago
were the newest
phone that we had.
So we have a lot of interesting
engineering challenges
to handle here.
And because of this, we need
as many developers in Facebook
to be tackling this, not just
a mobile team, obviously.
So today, I'm going to
tell you about, broadly,
mobile at Facebook.
And I could keep talking over
and over for hours about this.
I've picked a couple
selected topics here.
First, I guess the
complex is, we have 1.3
billion mobile monthly actives.
And this number is
growing every single day.
What do we do about this?
How do we handle it?
Where are the interesting
problems that arise?
We also want to make sure that
we ship really, really fast.
Just because we have a ton
of devices and a ton of users
does not mean that we should
be slowing ourselves down.
We ship an APK every week now.
Many of you guys, as you guys
are Android developers here,
you realize it's
actually really,
really tough to do this.
In addition to
that, we have a ton
of features in one single app.
We have a ton of developers.
Our app is feature packed.
How do we do it so that we do
this in a very reliable manner?
On Android, native
clients in particular,
we have a very low
tolerance for error.
We're dealing with state,
memory, networking,
a lot of these things
that are very, very
tricky to deal with in a very,
very constrained environment.
And once we actually
ship something out,
we can't assume that
with the next release,
no one will be
seeing this version.
We have a very low
tolerance for error.
So I'm going to tell you
a couple stories about how
Facebook handle a bunch
of these problems while
scaling in size and speed.
So, two ways.
First I'm going to talk
about coding at scale.
And the second part
is how we release
to the world in a very fast,
speedy, and reliable manner.
So let's talk about
coding at scale.
So I guess story time.
Around 2011 when I
started Facebook,
this was also
coincidentally the time
when we were
transitioning from having
just some small
core mobile teams
and having the whole company
jump in and do Android and iOS
development.
So was it as easy as it sounds?
Obviously not.
It was actually really scary.
I remember almost like, in
my mind, almost overnight,
the code base had transitioned
from probably a dozen engineers
to hundreds, probably
a hundred engineers.
I'm probably overacting.
It was probably like so many.
But still a lot.
So how did this affect my life?
You could never build.
Everything was crashy.
When you thought your feature,
when you finished writing
your code, nothing worked.
So obviously we realized
developer efficiency
was going to be affected
by having a lot of people
writing a lot of code.
So we realized that we had
to make some infrastructure
changes and cultural changes
for this to work out.
You can't just
transition from having
12 engineers to a
hundred in one day
and not expect hiccups here.
So we realized,
well first we need
to create an environment that
enforces testing, and also
makes it easy to write more
tests, just avoid brittle code.
And the second part is we
need to break dependencies
amongst the different teams.
What does that mean?
If I'm working on News Feed and
something on the photo upload
flow breaks or is
using a lot of memory,
me as a News Feed engineer, I
should not be blocked by that.
And I should be able
to build my code,
and you should be
able to deploy it.
So what did we do?
So we started using
dependency injection.
So many of you guys are
probably familiar with this.
But for those who are
not, dependency injection
is a design pattern
for externally setting
object dependencies and
separating the creation
versus the behavior.
What this does, naturally,
is that it encourages
modularity and testability.
You guys are probably familiar
with dependency injection
frameworks like Dagger
for instance and Guice.
Back in 2011, Dagger was not
available as an open source
framework, and Guice was
giving us performance problem.
So we developed our
own internal one.
But the inspiration and the
same principles still apply.
Now let me give an
example for those
who are not familiar with this.
The idea is, let's say
I'm creating a method that
fetches data for my News Feed.
Let's call it NewsFeedFetcher.
And it requires a lot
of different objects,
say an HttpRequestHelper
so that you can fetch
something, some
sort of JsonParser,
and some sort of
ImageDownloader.
All of those are
modular classes that
perform separate objectives.
So one way to construct this
dependency in a nice manner
is just within your constructor
or within your main method.
And within your class,
initialize them.
Called new HttpRequestHelper,
new parser, downloader,
et cetera.
So what happens here?
So the problem in
that case is that you
tangle a lot of
dependency creation
together with the objects.
And it's really,
really hard to test it.
So with dependency
injection, the idea
is that rather than
creating your dependencies,
you're going to assume
that they get passed
to you by some god
like injector class,
or just get passed you
by the constructor.
And you get this
@Inject annotation.
What this @Inject
annotation does
is it goes through all of the
methods that were annotated
like this, and creates an
injector global object,
a singleton, that when we're
asking for a particular object,
FetchNewsFeedMethod, will
pass all of these objects
during instantiation time.
And it will also, if you
want just one instance of it,
it will hold that instance,
and we won't recreate it.
What is the nice
thing about this?
If you're writing tests, you
can pass fake versions of it.
You keep a very clean interface.
And the other part is that
you can build your own module,
and then connect it to
the other ones as part
of the final version when
deploying and compiling
the app.
So this encourages
testability, code modularity,
and also helps us
scale our code base.
And this is obviously
really, really important
when you have tons of developers
writing code at the same time.
So one of the problems
here is performance.
Let me illustrate why
performance is a problem.
It lies on the area of
dependency resolution.
So at run time, because
you don't really
know who are the
objects that you're
going to be depending
on, we realize OK, you
hook that NewsFeedFetcher
to this HttpRequestHelper,
this parser, and
this downloader.
It's not until you initialize
the app during cold start
that you are doing
all of the stuff.
This takes us to a
different problem.
In order to have all
this flexibility,
our cold start time is just
going through the roof.
So what do we do here?
So we can actually switch
all of this to compile time.
But if we hard
coded everything, we
would go back into
the old method
where everything felt
wired and static.
And we wouldn't be able to
write tests in an easy manner.
So one of the
engineers at Facebook
thought, OK, instead, we should
look at the Java bytecode
and modify it at compile
time to substitute
the creators of this
providers into static methods,
and actually wire them
to the final versions.
And when you're doing tests,
you still get the flexibility.
At the end of the day, we
reduce start up time by 20%.
And you do all these
operations at compile time,
which happen offline.
So that's just one example
of how we actually broke down
a lot of our development
process, what
type of infrastructure
that we actually
put in place so that
we could move really
fast in an independent manner.
Here's an example of a diff
that we send out for review.
A lot of the internal
details are blurred here
for confidentiality purposes.
But what I want you
to pay attention to
is the green and
red blocks here.
Every time we send
a diff for review,
we run a lot of tests,
both unit, end to end,
and screenshot test.
This help us prevent
brittle code.
And if we create
the right framework
for the different teams to
start being able to write code,
we will be able to identify
a bunch of these failures
before we even land the
code so that our trunk is
in a healthier manner.
So the other part,
another trick that we
found that was very,
very useful when
scaling our mobile organization
is identifying common APIs.
Let me tell you one
example of a case study.
So if you're working on
a feature at Facebook,
there's chances that
you'll be needing
to download some
data from the cloud,
cache it somehow locally, and
show it in some sort of UI.
So this obviously involves
writing some sort of code.
And, well, the reality is
that we have a lot of features
and a lot of engineers,
and each of them
writes their own version.
You might be wondering,
why can't this
be abstracted into
a common library?
Well, let's think about the
case of fetching your News
Feed versus fetching photos,
fetching events, et cetera.
The structure of your query
changes drastically depending
on what you're trying to do.
So there is some sort of custom
code that has to be written.
You can call a general
HTTP library, you
but you still have to
construct the parameters
that you're asking-- the
API call with the parameters
that you want.
So this happen across the board.
And at some point,
one of our engineers
decided hey, this
underlying API method call,
I'd like to optimize it.
But then he realized,
uh oh, in order
to make an optimization
to the fetching mechanism,
you have to change every
single line of code
in many, many
different products.
And when you do that, it
doesn't come for free.
This is not that simple.
You could be breaking
some other product code.
And people get pissed,
and it's actually really,
really tedious.
So one of the ideas
that we came up with
is instead, write a small
snippet of what you're
trying to-- in a small
snippet of a text file,
specify what you're going to
try to download from the server.
And have a library autogenerate
the actual API method calls
from that templated version.
What this does is this
allows for making changes
in the particular underlying
architecture to be much easier
and not affect that much
of the product internals.
So the engineers that work
on this type of optimizations
and developer APIs at
Facebook are called product
infrastructure engineers.
And their objective is to make
it easier for product teams
to develop faster.
So I guess that's kind of my
high level overview of how
Facebook as an
organization has scaled
from having a small
group of engineers
working on mobile to the
whole company touching it.
Now I'm going to
switch gears and talk
a little bit about how we
release our app into the world.
So if you guys were
at the talk yesterday
on emerging markets
for Facebook,
we talked about how we have
over 10,000 different Android
devices out there.
Over 10,000 different
devices are running Facebook,
which is kind of scary.
We need to make sure that our
app works in all of these cases
and is not creating a
terrible experience.
So how do we do that?
Well, we have a ton of different
layers of support here.
The first one is
employee dogfooding.
Let's say I'm building
my particular feature,
and I'm pretty
sure that it works.
But I don't know.
There's 10,000
different devices.
There's a lot of different
connectivity types.
And to be honest, a lot
of different use cases.
So rely on our employee
dogfooding program.
We have thousands of
engineers at Facebook,
and we really encourage a
lot of them to use Android.
And we have this Rage
Shake feature support.
Again, if you provide the
right tools for people
to report a lot of
this information,
it makes it easier.
So if you find something
that doesn't feel right
or an experience that
is really bothering you,
you Rage Shake your phone.
And then you get to
write an employee report.
So is that enough?
Well, the answer is no.
So we take advantage of the
Google Play's alpha and beta
channels.
We have over
100,000 alpha users,
and we have a little over a
million beta testers right now.
So we release our app
into alpha every day,
a new version of master into
that, and every couple of days
into beta.
This allows us to turn
on our features early.
So if you guys are
interested in staying up
to date with the newest
Facebook features,
we turn them on much more often
in the alpha and beta channels.
And we turn them
down in production.
So check out those channels.
By looking at this,
we're able to do
identify crash rates mostly and
see some of our obvious booting
problems.
Now this is not
perfect, because most
of the users in the
alpha and beta channels
have really high end phones.
Most of the phones
are Nexus phones.
So it's a little skewed towards
a very tech oriented audience.
Nonetheless, that
is very helpful.
If everything passes here,
if everything looks good,
we release to a small
percentage of the world.
Now I mentioned
this is our release.
We have multiple releases
of different products
all the time.
But we're very, very careful.
Sometimes if we are looking
at product changes that
affect a lot of users
and are pretty obvious,
we run tests in
countries in particular
to see where the longer
term network affect's there.
And sometimes if it's something
smaller, we will run a 1% test,
look at engagement
metrics and keep rolling
to a larger audience that way.
But is this enough?
The answer is no.
Let me tell you a
story about something
that we didn't catch
in the employee dogfood
program, the alpha,
or beta releases,
or even when we
rolled out slowly.
So this was in the context
of a photo uploader.
So I guess this
might look familiar.
If we are trying
to show a progress
bar for uploading
photos, your code
might look something like this.
Obviously I
simplified a lot here.
Here it's saying, hey
you're uploading photos
at 70% of the total.
So we go through a phase
of internationalization
of strings.
So obviously, when you multiply
that number in Android,
the placeholder percent
d, and it will actually
substitute a number.
So that's probably pretty
clear for this crowd.
When we translate stuff,
we send our strings--
uploading photos, whatever--
into our internationalization
console.
And we have a lot of
volunteer translators.
So in the case of Finnish,
Danish, and Polish,
I had a single
translator doing this.
They thought oh, this percent
sign was probably a mistake.
So they removed it
in the translation.
So what happens here?
There's no crash.
No crash happens here.
Well, there's a crash.
But there's no
compilation mistake here.
So everything still builds.
Depending on how you write your
code, it could a soft error,
or it could be a
cancellation of uploads,
or it could be a crash.
So regardless, this means
that our users in the Nordics
are not getting a photo uploads.
Now the reason why this
was even more subtle
is because we have separate
experiences for low end
phones and high end phones.
So this was just happening
for Gingerbread users
in Finish, Polish, and Danish.
So we did not have anyone in
the alpha or beta channels that
used any of these
particular cases.
So how did we catch it?
We immediately saw an
increase in upload failures,
in this particular scenario.
We drilled more into
this, and identified this.
So we have very, very
targeted instrumentation tools
so that we can identify
large changes in engagement.
And sometimes many of this
are related to releases.
And then we can actually
bisect and identify
what the particular problem is.
So is this enough?
So I touched a little
bit into the analytics.
How do we understand that
our app is doing well once we
release it to the world?
So we have a lot of
dependencies and a lot of tools
that we can use.
Examples are crash logs, bug
reports, and Google Play store
reviews.
Everything in this form
comes like a snippet of text.
Even a crash report, if
you look at your ADB stack,
you're waiting for the
particular pattern.
You're catching it,
and you're storing it.
None of this structured,
especially like Rage Shake
reports.
People say, oh my feed is not
loading, or I can't comment.
Those are examples.
But we get thousands
and thousands a day
reports of this kind, mostly
because of our magnitude.
So one of the
things that we do is
we use machine learning and
natural language processing
to cluster a lot of this
reports using keywords.
And we identify which
are the main categories.
This allows us to focus
on the most pressing bugs
and be able to cut by different
device classes, features, et
cetera.
And this is how we identify
some of our most alarming bugs.
And we have task forces to
focus on them in particular.
Examples are like hey,
if people can't like,
what's happening here?
Or if your News Feed is
not loading, we drill down.
I don't understand,
add more logging,
and come back and forth.
So this is an example
of a screenshot
that our engineers look
at when they get a crash.
I have, again, blurred a bunch
of our internal data here.
But the structure here
is that to the left,
you get your stack trace
after all the clustering that
happened.
And to the right, we get
aggregate crash summaries.
For instance, how often
is this happening?
What device classes
Since which version are we
seeing a lot of this stuff?
These are all the tools that we
can give our engineers so they
can reproduce this and address
a lot of these crashes in a much
more promptly manner.
So ever since we started
having these tools,
these help reduce crashes
by 75%, which is a lot.
What does this say?
If we build the
right infrastructure,
if we build the
right tools, we will
be able to target the problems
in a much clearer manner.
So that's all I have here today.
It looks like we have
a much larger slot.
And I have a 30
minute talk prepared,
but I'll start taking questions.
And there are a bunch
of us from Facebook
here if you guys have
broad questions as well.
AUDIENCE: How do you assess
the severity of a bug,
or how do you prioritize
bugs across the different
[INAUDIBLE]?
JENNY YUEN: So the
question-- I'll
repeat that-- is
how do you identify
the severity of the bug, and
how do you prioritize it?
Well, so remember
that slide that I
talked about where we have a lot
of input of reports, crashes,
et cetera?
So we have information like, how
often is this being reported?
So if people are pressing the
report a bug button, the more
they report it, it indicates
a lot more severity
and like a broader use case.
So we have a program
at Facebook called
the Countdown, the Countdown
kind of like program
where we look at
all of the bugs that
are being reported, the ones
that are reported the most.
And we have specific task
forces to handle each of them.
Some of them are
easier than others.
Some of them are because we
release something by mistake
and we can do immediate
targeted fixes.
Some of them are more subtle.
Let me give you an example.
We had a like reliability
problem at some point.
People couldn't like.
But if this was
really mainstream,
like obvious problem, we
would have realized this,
and we could have targeted.
It was not the case.
It was pretty subtle.
And we broke down a bunch
of the different cases
by adding a bunch of
logging and looking
at what are the reports are.
In some cases, in low
connectivity scenarios,
people were hitting like,
but this was not propagating.
And they hit like a lot, like,
and like, like, and like.
And our site integrity,
or like our spam filter
detection mechanisms
realized, OK, you
can't be liking
this story a ton.
We're going to block.
We're going to
essentially block you.
But this was happening because
people were pressing this back
and forth.
It was queueing up
on the client side.
And when the connectivity came
back up, all the queue of likes
and likes, a request
was coming on to server.
So we were able
to identify that.
And we were able to remove
all those likes and likes
and fix that.
So that's one
example of a problem.
But since this is affecting
some of our core functionally,
having signals of how
often it is being reported
helps us identify
the severity of them.
Does that help
answer you question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What sort
of testing process
do you have in place that
would allow you to release
an app on a weekly basis?
JENNY YUEN: So the question was,
what type of testing processes
do you have in
place that allow you
to release on a weekly basis?
So we just started transitioning
from a two week release cycle
to a one week release
cycle recently.
So let me give you a little
more historical context.
We used to release once a month.
We used to not have
a release schedule.
We were ready to release,
and then we released it.
This is back in the
days when we had
probably a small mobile team.
We had a big rewrite,
we released it.
Then we switched to
release once a month
when we started
having a lot of people
developing in the codebase.
We used to have a month
soak period and a month--
you branch cut, and you
have a month soak period.
And only bug fixes go in there.
It was really tough
because suddenly,
if you couldn't get your
feature for the month,
you had to actually
wait for another month.
And reliability was
super important.
So we started by having
a lot of unit tests,
like setting a lot of the-- the
dependency injection framework
integration was mostly so that
we could even write unit tests.
So that started first.
And then with time,
we realized that hey,
now that we're
releasing every week,
it's really hard to have
manual testing in place.
We used to have a
QA testing team that
looked at a bunch of
the core interactions
to make sure, say, you
could load your News Feed,
you could post a photo,
you could like a story.
Like a lot of our
core interactions,
they would manually test a
lot of our core interactions
before we shipped.
Now with a one week release
cycle, that's impossible.
So we have a really good
end to end testing framework
and screenshot testing
framework that we use now.
A screenshot testing
framework operates
a lot like a unit test.
It allows you to separate
a lot of the components,
and it takes a
screenshot of a lot of UI
that you have so that
it can compare it
with the old version.
And it can ask you, hey,
do you mean for this
to be a difference?
So if we have
undesired changes, we
can actually
identify them early.
Our end to end tests
are meant to substitute
some of our manual testing.
As a principle, we're asking
all of the product teams
to sort of transition to this.
So how do we enforce it?
We have this concept of
a test storm happening.
At Facebook, we
have a lot of trials
of what would happen
if our data center,
if X data center went down.
So we want to actually
understand our weaknesses
there.
So what would happen if
our QA testing team just
was not available?
So we're having
a test storm plan
where our objective
is to transition
a lot of our manual testing
into end to end tests.
So the answer is,
there's a mix of stuff.
We have a lot of
tools now that allow
us to write from all
the way from unit tests
to end to end tests.
And the idea is to
prevent regression
so that we don't have to be
fixing stuff after launch.
AUDIENCE: How do
you find the balance
between the staged rollouts,
just lower percentage
of whatever versus having
a consistent experience
across all customers?
JENNY YUEN: So the
question is, how do we
find the balance
between a staged roll
out and a consistent experience
amongst different people?
Well, so we release
our app once a week.
That is a staged
rollout on its own.
We want to make sure that
we monitor a lot of things
like crash rates, bug reports.
So we want to be
very, very careful
about not introducing a
release that is bad for users.
So in that sense, we will
have a gradual rollout.
That being said, we do a
lot of experimentations
in our features because
we want to make sure
that whatever we
roll out to 100%
is the best experience
for our users.
Let me give you an example.
When we redid the way we
navigate to open comments,
we had a new, very
fancy design that when
you tapped on comments,
it opened a popover.
It was bouncy.
It was very friendly.
But we found out that
hey, if you actually
looked at low end device users,
they were actually having
a terrible experience.
They were commenting less.
So we dug in a little bit more.
We actually opened this
in a low end phone,
and we realized that
animation is so choppy,
there's really no
point in having it.
So if we had released the
one version to everybody,
we would have hurt
our low end users,
and seen better
engagement, and have
a better, more delightful
experience for high end users.
But because we had the way to
look at all these analytics,
we were able to pinpoint that
for some users, this is bad.
And for some of the
users it's better.
So what we did in
that case is we
turned off animation
for our low end users.
And they actually got to
experience the full screen
behavior that we had, which
was better than the old one,
but they didn't
need animation that
was going to be choppy anyway.
So I guess to answer
your question,
one of the things we learned
is that there's no one
size fits all for everybody.
There's a lot of diversity in
device models, in screen sizes,
in usages, in general usage,
not just from your device,
but also culturally speaking.
For instance, people
in different countries
have different ratios of
friends versus page content.
And people use Facebook in
a slightly different manner.
So the important
thing for us is to be
able to understand our
users in the best manner
and provide them with what
will make them have a better
experience.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you guys
leverage any feature clipping?
JENNY YUEN: What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Like ship a
feature turned off, and then
turn it on later?
JENNY YUEN: The question is if
we leverage any centers where
we turn on the feature then
turn off and turn it on.
I can't think of
a particular one,
but do you have an
example in mind?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you may
ship-- like for an A/B testing
scenario, instead of doing
two different builds,
you ship one build
with a flag that
says use this like button
or that like button.
And then you turn
that on and off
to determine which one's better.
You could use for A/B
testing, or it could be good
for, I guess keeping code that's
not yet ready for full release,
but it's not holding
up your release cycle.
JENNY YUEN: Yeah, we
do that all the time.
In fact, we have a
lot of experiments
running simultaneously.
We have a very good
experimentation framework.
It was built internally.
Literally, probably every
single product change,
and any large
infrastructure change
will go through
experimentation here.
The context being--
For instance, if
you have a refactor,
you want to make sure that
all your metrics are neutral.
And if they're not, you
want to understand why,
because it's probably
a bug otherwise.
For our products, we
constantly roll out
this in terms of tests.
The set up of the test matters.
It varies a lot depending on
what the test is in particular.
But is there something in
particular you had in mind?
AUDIENCE: No.
I'm just curious if you do that
at build time with variance,
or so you a particular
APK that's configured
a particular way, or
is that controlled--
JENNY YUEN: Server control.
AUDIENCE: On your server?
JENNY YUEN: It's all
server controlled.
So the way it works
is that we have--
the system we call is a
quick experimentation system.
It's like internal.
We call it that.
And also we have a
gating system for that.
And a lot of the
signals, every six hours,
we download some small
snippet information.
Which is like, imagine a table.
It's like a name of
experiments mapped to the group
that you're assigned to.
And depending on which
group you're assigned to,
your code actually decides
to turn this on or off,
kind of like log a lot of
user engagement information,
like your behavior, the
behavior of the user,
depending on the flow.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What kinds
of tools and processes
do you have around code reviews?
JENNY YUEN: The
question is, what type
of tools and processes do
we have around code reviews?
So it really
depends by the team.
So we are a very bottoms
up company in the sense
that we try not to build
things are not necessary.
But that being said.
The common things that
come up is automatically
running the test is something
that has been found very
useful across all the teams.
So by the time your
review comes back,
we are able to run a
bunch of unit tests
or end to end
tests in that case.
I guess we have general
linters and a bunch
of agreed upon
patterns that we like
to enforce so that our code
is consistent and coherent
across everything.
What else?
Yeah, I think at a high level,
that's what I'm thinking of.
We do like to, kind
of like in principle,
say, hey, if you are
done building a feature,
because end to end tests
are heavy and expensive--
Let's say we ship this,
and we agreed on this
as being the feature that
we want to actually release
and in this form,
we go back and start
looking at what are
the core tests that we
would like to build.
And from the point
of view of a user.
And we try to do that.
Yeah, we'll start here.
AUDIENCE: When you
went from 12 engineers
to 60 engineers on
your web platform,
how did your codebase change?
Did you start to break
up the different modules
or [INAUDIBLE] you get?
JENNY YUEN: So the
question is, what
happened when you
switch from 12 engineers
to hundreds of engineers?
How did your code change?
From my memory, the biggest
thing that changed was we
started using
dependency injection,
because everything
was tangled together,
and stuff was breaking.
And if you could build
a particular module
and just not have
to depend on it,
it's actually really helpful.
The second one that we built,
that we developed because we
didn't find a tool that could
handle a bunch of our scale
was Buck, our build system.
So the way Buck works is that
it builds particular modules.
And it doesn't rebuild them
if they haven't changed.
Buck is a general build system.
It's actually open source.
It's not specific to Android.
It's part of our iOS
build system as well now.
But the advantage
of that was, we used
have a single-- we still
have a single repository.
But each of our
modules have to be--
like when building the whole
thing, it would take forever.
With time, what we
developed was different ways
of distributing the builds
across different machines
so that not everything
lies on your laptop.
And your laptop doesn't look
like it's starting up a rocket.
It doesn't sound
like a rocket ship.
So Buck was pretty impactful.
What other things did we change?
The stuff I was mentioning,
I was mentioning here
how we fetch data
from our servers.
It's a framework called GraphQL.
It's open source now.
It allows us to
effectively download--
it's an API that allows us
to effectively download data
from our servers.
But it's also tolerant
to versioning.
What do I mean with this?
So we all know that our--
the APK that we probably
released a couple months ago,
it's still out in the wild.
So we can't deprecate
certain methods.
So rather than saying,
hey, this is API,
and we're switching it like
this in the next release, which
doesn't really work.
We came up with an API
construction that allows
us to ask for specific parts.
For instance, if we are
rendering News Feed,
it's pass me all the stories.
Pass me the message of it.
Pass me the link for it.
Pass me the photo.
And what if, in the next
version of News Feed,
first we were not
rendering photos.
And we're just rendering
everything like a text piece.
And in the next version, we want
to have a rich media format.
So how do we repurpose this API
so that the old version still
keeps working and we don't have
to change our signature a lot.
In new ones, we can support
a bunch of this stuff.
We use the concept of a stylist.
The idea is in JSON,
as part of your JSON,
you have a stylist that says, I
want to render you as a photo.
And as a photo, if
it's as a photo format,
you need to make sure that
your image URL is there,
and the title is there.
And if you can't
render a photo, there's
a fallback mechanism, which
is just text for instance.
And this is how we grow.
So that has been very helpful.
So check it out.
A lot of this is part of
like a framework of GraphQL,
but also a lot of this was
custom within our team.
AUDIENCE: Do you
design for the low end
first and then
progressively enhance,
or do you design for the
high end and [INAUDIBLE]?
JENNY YUEN: So the
question is, do we
design for the low end
first and progressively
enhance, or the other way?
So we have someone from the
emerging markets in here.
Like I don't want to
put you on the spot.
I can answer it, but
it seems like you
will able to add color.
So I'll take a
stab, and then Alex
can probably add here more.
To be honest, we tried
to build empathy.
That's the most important thing.
One of the things we realized
is that first, [INAUDIBLE]
an Android phone, you need to
use an Android phone everyday
too so that you can understand
how navigation works,
what type of limitations
of hardware we have.
So we make sure that
we really, really push
every one at the companies
to start using Android.
A couple things
that we also tried
is low end phone
versus high end phone.
This started with one of
our PMs, Chis Marra, who
started raising a
lot of awareness
about the different types
of phones out there.
So he asked, can everyone carry
a low end phone and a high end
phone?
The other part is we
build a lot of APIs
so that people can
understand the data
and be able to cut it
across different device
models and different kind
of [INAUDIBLE] models.
What does that mean?
Well, so if you guys
attended the talk yesterday,
we talked about how we have
10,000 different devices.
And when we have 10,000
different devices,
are you supposed to carry
10,000 different phones,
test all of them?
It's literally
impossible to do that.
But what we do
know is that there
are certain characteristics
that differentiate
them-- the number of cores,
the screen size, basically
their speed.
So rather than thinking
about each of the devices,
we think about if you took
this phone, the specifications
of this phone, how
will you map it
to-- when was it the newest
flagship phone in the US?
So the same way you
think about car models,
I don't really know about the
models everywhere in the world.
But I can think of, OK, this
is a car that would have
released in 2010 for instance.
So we created this
year class model
so that instead of thinking
about 10,000 different phones,
you think about five or six,
or really just fast and slow.
So probably the ones in your
pockets are the fast ones,
and think about something
that was flagship in 2011.
So when we have this
type of framework,
we can cut our data
across [INAUDIBLE] there.
So that's one part, be able
to understand your data.
And the second part
is also, try to use
this phone and this model.
The emerging
markets team started
what we call 2G Tuesday.
The idea is on
Tuesday, you will have
an ad on top of
your Facebook that
says-- a megaphone
we call it-- that
says, can you start
using Facebook
as if we slowed down everything
and you were in a 2G network,
examples like this.
So all of this, those
are the objective
of building empathy so that
our designers, our product
developers, and our
product managers
can think about where the
problems are happening
everywhere.
In addition to
that, we also have
a lot of research field trips
going to different emerging
markets.
So I know we got to
India, Southeast Asia.
We go to Mexico.
And we interview
a bunch of people
and ask them about
their usage patterns.
This helps us to
understand emerging markets
as well as cultural
differences too.
Do you want to add
something Alex?
ALEX: Nope, it's a good answer.
AUDIENCE: So you're
mentioning that you're moving
to a weekly release cycle.
I was just curious how you
managed the exponential upgrade
path that users can
potentially go through,
not to mention preloads as well.
JENNY YUEN: Exponential
upgrade paths?
What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So if someone didn't
take your upgrade this week,
they're potentially three weeks
older versus two weeks older.
And then next week, there's
an entire new [INAUDIBLE]
upgrades to deal with.
JENNY YUEN: I'll try to
repeat it for everybody.
So when you switch to a
one week release cycle,
and people haven't
upgraded in two weeks,
and this person hasn't
upgraded in one week.
Suddenly you have
the newest version
that you have out,
but really have
a bunch of people in the
prior one, the one before.
And it blows up a
lot more than if you
were releasing twice a
week-- like twice a month,
for instance.
Is that the context?
Yeah, the problem is
that it's not simple.
We've been dealing
with this problem
ever since we were even
releasing once a month,
Android in particular.
iOS users actually upgrade
much faster than Android users.
It's probably pretty
obvious why because
of the different network
connections, et cetera as well.
So on Android-- I guess to
contrast a little bit with iOS,
iOS doesn't have an
alpha beta channel.
We have one, which is nice.
It's not enough fully, but
we'll take what we can get.
We still have versions
that exist out there.
I remember seeing like
a bug of version--
a server side
change that we made
by mistake that was breaking
a release that came out
a year ago.
So we are still handling--
We are still handling binaries
that were released a year ago.
And the answer for that is we
have to be very, very flexible.
And we really need
to-- we can never
assume that an APK that is
released will disappear.
So what do we do?
We need to make sure that
before we release everything,
we have tested everything.
This is why testing
is really important.
Instrumentation is
super important.
The most important thing is that
we need to design our server
APIs in a flexible manner,
because you cannot assume that
you can deprecate a function.
So rather than saying this is
the version, version 1, version
2 of the API call,
we need to invert it.
We need to think about--
We need to think about
how do you expose things
where the client is saying,
give me this information, rather
than giving-- for instance,
in the case of News Feed,
is give me the last 10 stories
with this particular fields,
as opposed to saying,
just give me feed.
Because that will change.
So if you tell the server,
give me the last ten
stories with the message, with
the image, with the image URL,
it's very different
from just give me feed.
And I changed the signature.
So that's by design in the
APIs that we have to do.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is the
Facebook testing
tools and the infrastructure
that you mentioned open source?
JENNY YUEN: So question is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JENNY YUEN: So the question is
if our infrastructure-- I guess
I'll rephrase it a little bit.
Let me know if it's accurate.
Which internal tools are open
source that are available?
So not everything to be honest.
So what we do is we
want to make sure
that a lot of the stuff
that we open source
is packaged correctly,
and it works well,
and its generic enough
for people to use.
We do open source
a lot of stuff.
The screenshot tests work.
The author is Arnold Noronha.
He is an engineer in New York
on the infrastructure team.
He just released that.
So if you're making
a lot of UI changes
and you want to make sure
that stuff is consistent,
check that out.
It's called Android
screenshot test framework.
Unit test, we just use
standard JUnit stuff.
The end to end test
framework, we're
actually pulling from the open
source framework community.
We use Selendroid.
So we kind of repurpose it
to use our internal tooling,
but it comes from open source.
The dependency injection
framework is not open source.
It's very similar to
Dagger, so I encourage
you to check that one out.
Check out our--
so we have a page
for a bunch of our
Facebook open source tools.
That will have information
about the different projects.
Another cool one is Rebound.
It's a UI library
that allows you
to make bouncy animations
so that you can use spring
physics to create elements.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JENNY YUEN: Chat heads.
That comes from Rebound.
So I know a lot of companies
have used that one.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Have you started
looking [INAUDIBLE]
JENNY YUEN: So let me see if I
heard the question correctly.
When you said that
we transitioned
from mobile to
everyone writing code,
did they all have
mobile experience?
How do we handle
a bunch of that?
The answer is, we need a
lot of mobile engineers.
We are hiring a lot for
Android and iOS engineers.
So if anyone is looking for a
job, come talk to us as well.
That's my plug for hiring.
But the point is,
because Android and iOS--
mobile technologies are fairly
new compared to say, web
technologies or
systems in general,
we could not hire enough
people to work on Android.
We could not hire enough people
to satisfy the rate at which we
needed people.
So a couple things we did.
The first thing is we
hired an in house company
to come teach us how to do
Android, Big Nerd Ranch.
So I part of the first
class doing there.
I was not an Android developer
before I joined Facebook.
I was actually doing machine
learning and computer vision.
So we transitioned there.
One of the things we found
out is that, well, you know,
it's a language.
It's a different framework.
But it's still programming.
You're dealing with
building a system that
is going to be having
a lot of uptime
in a very resource
constrained environment.
So a lot of the people that
have worked on systems and web
can apply a lot of that
knowledge into Android itself.
And they have to
learn about a bunch
of like the general
framework details.
So we have found that a
lot of our web and systems
engineers at Facebook have
been very, very-- have
contributed a lot
to how our internals
and how our architecture
patterns have been [INAUDIBLE].
The second part
is we realized OK,
since we can't hire
enough Android people,
how about we train them?
So at Facebook we have
our bootcamp program.
When we hire you
into Facebook, we
don't preallocate
you into a team.
We have some custom
pipelines that do,
but most people are generalists.
And they go through
six weeks of classes
where they learn how to
use our full systems.
And back in the day, it was
only the web and the C++ layer.
And then we realized, OK,
we need to add something
for mobile, Android and iOS.
So if you join Facebook now,
after three weeks of learning
how to use the general web
stack and the system stack,
we give you the option to join
the iOS track or the Android
track, or stay in
the systems track.
And at that point,
we teach classes.
The classes are
all internal now.
We developed our
internal curriculum.
For one week, you learn how
to write Android from scratch
without the Facebook libraries.
You build an Instagram app,
like a baby Instagram app.
And after that first week--
so it's a very intense week.
And after that, you
learn a lot about how
to use the Android specific
tools, or iOS specific tools.
And you start talking
to different teams.
And then by two weeks in,
you're already contributing
to our mobile codebases.
So this is how we
have handled the fact
that there's not enough
Android developers out there.
So we train them.
And that has worked out well.
And we're still
looking for people.
Any other questions?
OK.
I guess if there are
no more questions,
I'll stick around here.
Feel free to stop by, chat.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]